grace is an australian computer
programmer
she has just received a job offer from a
tech company in germany and is planning
to move to the eu
cue administrative hassle and paperwork
right
in fact no
have you heard of the blue card it is a
system that allows highly skilled people
from outside the eu to come and work in
a european country more easily
the eu's population is aging and some
sectors like computer programming are
seeing a shortage of new workers
[Music]
the blue card is a way to support
european businesses by making the eu
market more easily accessible to highly
skilled foreign workers like grace
to get her blue card she will need to
prove that she has an eu work contract
or a binding job offer of at least six
months and have her health insurance in
order
the card will soon have more relaxed
eligibility criteria
simplified conditions to bring families
together
and will ensure better rights for
workers
while the card is an eu program european
countries are in charge of issuing and
withdrawing them
the european parliament supports wider
access for qualified workers and the
simplification of movement within the eu
for blue card holders
[Music]